[Music]
let's get you up to date on the
coronavirus numbers nevada reports 350
new cases just slightly higher than what
we've seen the in the past
week test positivity remains unchanged
at 4.2 percent
now clark county reported just over 250
new cases
and seven deaths when it comes to the
recovery rate while it's still
is sitting right now high at 96 percent
well the state's mitigation task force
says the cases are starting to level off
with the number of cases stabilizing the
state says it does not expect to see
any significant decline in the near
future during the covet 19 mitigation
task force meeting
the question of will restaurants have to
meet social distancing
and hygiene requirements came up they
say the goal
is to have clear answer early next week
i don't want to get down too into the
weeds of um
of where we are on that because there's
there are decisions yet to be made
but our goal is to make sure we meet the
uh the spirit and the letter of the
directive going to
may 1st and local transition my lean
grace
well as far as schools and graduations
go schools may now apply for large
gatherings
those events will transition to the
county starting may first